let's talk about self-care
if you're getting out of the shower and
you're looking down and you can't see
your johnson because your belly fat
is hiding it you have a problem there's
a lot of guys out there right now
that have i've i've i flush more
testosterone down the toilet when i take
a dump
than what most guys have in their body
today they're walking around weak
they don't pick up heavy things and put
them down they don't lift
they don't get into combat sports and
learn how to use their hands and their
body to be lethal
i just said five ten minutes ago what do
women want women want
a lethal man that is civilized marinate
on that for a little bit
what is the lethal men that is civilized
look like let me think here
hmm who is a popular who's the highest
paid
hollywood actor today that does action
movies let me think who would that be
that would be dwayne the rock johnson
yeah
what is he he's a big badass
tatted bald strong dude
he looks lethal af that's why they cast
him for those roles and that's why women
go and watch those movies okay you have
to understand
that self-care does matter and the
optics of strength
projecting it outwardly matters and just
because you're not going to go to the
gym or learn a combat sports
or do things that develop competency
skills with your body you've been
designed to move
for millions of years through evolution
not sit at a computer in an
office or at a desk all day on your ass
doing nothing you've been designed
to hike 20 miles and and hunt
saber-toothed tigers with other men with
spears and bows and axes and [ __ ] like
that
you haven't been designed to sit around
obese i don't know what the stat is now
it's like something like 41 or 43
of the american population is
clinically obese okay that means you're
fat it means that you're carrying too
much
visceral fat on your body and it is
unhealthy that's why we have
everybody out there with like things
like diabetes and all this stuff
they didn't have that a thousand years
ago because they had
higher quality calories and they also
moved a hell of a lot more
so if you're forced you know like if
you've gotten yourself in a position
let's say you're an
engineer and you're sitting at a
drafting board all day and you're like
but rich
i have to sit inside this is my job this
is what cool i don't know get a stand-up
desk get a stand-up desk with a
treadmill
uh get out on your breaks and lunches
and walk around the block
do push-ups on your brakes get a chin-up
bar at the office and do some chin-ups
i had the guys in my office once say to
me hey we got that space in the back
where you store your car in the winter
can we turn it into a gym
sure no problem here's five thousand
dollars go buy some gym equipment and
they did
right and these guys were working out on
the breaks and lunches and afternoon and
you know benching and chin ups and using
the bikes and all that sort of stuff
uh it's you know it's incumbent upon you
like i mentioned earlier
guys to take control of your life
self-care is an important part of that
self-card doesn't just mean your
physical body it also means your
spiritual mind
okay the mindset that you have a lot of
these things are
fully aligned with self-care that i'm
describing you know to you right now